you mentioned something about
do cellular automata exist outside the
human mind
in our little offline conversation
um why is that an interesting question
so uh cellular automata complexity
what's the relationship between
complexity and the human mind
and uh trees falling in the forest
infrastructure so the ca so when john
von neumann and conway and feynman were
doing c8s are doing on paper ca is
cellular
just drawing them on paper
how awesome is that that they were doing
cellular automata on paper yeah and then
they were doing a computer that takes
like forever to print out anything and
program sure people are now with the
tick tock kids these days with the tick
tock
don't understand how amazing it is to
just play with cellular automata
arbitrarily changing the rules as you
want initial conditions and see the
beautiful
patterns emerge sing with fractals all
of them
all you've just given me a brilliant
idea i wonder if there's a tick tock
account that's just dedicated to putting
out ca rules and there isn't we should
make one
100
and now we'll get so we have millions of
views like millions yes no you'll get uh
you'll get dozens just have that running
i'm saying look i i kind of
ca i love cas
yeah no i just
a few years ago i made some robots that
talked to each other chemical robots
that played the game of hex
um invented by john nash
um by doing chemistry and they
communicated via twitter
which were experiments they were doing
and they had a they had they had a they
had a lookup table of experiments and
robot one said i'm doing experiment 10.
and the other way about okay i'll do
experiment one then and they're
communicated by twister and then
publicly or yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh uh can you maybe
quickly explain what the game of hex is
uh yes so it's a basically a
hexagonal board and you try and
basically you color each hexa each
element on the board at eight hexagon
and you try and get from one side to the
other and the other one tries to block
you wait uh how are they connected well
so what the right place is this is the
chemical
uh yeah let's go back so they wrote two
robots yeah each robot was doing dye
chemistry so making rgb red green blue
red green blue red green blue and they
could just choose from experiments to do
red green blue um initially i said to my
group we need to make two chemical
robots that play chess and my group were
like
that's too hard no complicated go away
um but anyways we had the robot
people listening to this uh should
probably know that lee cronin is a as a
amazing group of brilliant people
he's exceptionally well published he's
written a huge number of amazing papers
whenever he uh calls himself stupid and
is is a sign of humility and i deeply
respect that and appreciate it so people
listening to this should know this is
this is a world-class scientist who
doesn't take him so seriously which i
really appreciate and love anywho
talking about serious science
we're back to uh
your group rejecting your idea of
chemical robots playing chess
via
dyes
so you went to a simpler game of hex
okay so what else the team that did it
were brilliant i really think
i think they still have ptsd from doing
it because i said this is a workshop
what i'd often do is i'd so i have about
60 people in my team and occasionally
before lockdown i would say
i'm a bit bored we're gonna we're gonna
have a workshop on something who wants
to come and then basically about 20
people turn up to my office and i say
we're gonna do this mad thing
and then it would just self organize and
some of them will they no i'm not doing
this and then you get lu you get left
with the the happy dozen yeah and what
we did is we built this robot and doing
diet chemistry is really easy you can
just take two molecules react them
together and change color
and what i wanted to do is have a
palette of different molecules you can
react commentarily and get different
colors so you've got two robots and i
went wouldn't it be cool if the robots
basically shared the same list of
reactions to do and they said oh and
because then you could do a kind of
multi-core
chemistry like they weren't so you have
two chemical reactions going on at once
and they could basically outsource the
problem but they're sharing the same
tape exactly okay so robot one would say
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do experiment one
and the other robot says i'll do
experiment 100. and then they co they
cross it off but i wanted to make it
that's brilliant by the way that is
genius so well i i wanted to make it
groovier and i said look let's have him
competing yeah to make to so playing a
game of hex and so when the robot does a
it does an experiment
and the more blue the die the more it
gets the the chart the higher chance it
gets to make the move it wants on the
hex board
so if it gets a red color it's like it
gets down weighted in the other robot
and so what the robots could do is they
play each player move
and because the fitness function or the
the optimization function was to make
the color blue they started to invent um
reactions we didn't weren't on the list
and they did this by not cleaning
because we made cleaning optional so
when one robot realized if it didn't
clean its pipes it could get blue more
quickly yeah and the other robot
realized that so it's like getting dirty
as well and they
unintended consequences of super
intelligence okay
but that was the game and we were
communicating to twitter though they
were they were doing it through twitter
and twitter blamed them a couple of
times i said come on you've got a couple
of robots doing chemistry it's really
cool stop banning them yeah but in the
end they had we had to take them off
twitter and they just communicated virus
server because it was just there were
people saying you could still find it
cronin lab 1 and cronin lab 2 on twitter
and it was like make move wait you know
mix a and b wait 10 seconds yeah answer
blue you know i i really find it super
compelling that
you would have a chemical entity
that's communicating with the world
that was one of the things i want to do
in my origin of life reaction right is
basically
have a
have a reactor
that's basically just randomly
enumerating through chemical space and
have some kind of cycle
and then read out what the molecule is
reading out using a mass spectrometer
and then convert that to text and
publish it on twitter and then wait
until it says i'm alive
i reckon that would i reckon that that
twitter account will get a lot of
followers yeah and i'm still trying to
convince my group that we should just
make an origin of life twitter account
where it's going
to be like hello testing
i'm here
well i'll share it i like it i
particularly enjoy this idea
of a non-human entity communicating with
the world via a human designed social
network is quite a
quite a beautiful idea
how we were talking about
uh ca's existing outside the human mind
yeah so i really admire stephen wolfram
i think he's a genius clearly
a genius and trapped in his actually
it's like a problem with being so smart
is you get trapped in your own you know
mind right
and i've i tried to actually i tried to
convince stephen that assembly theory
wasn't nonsense he was like no it's just
nonsense
i was a little bit sad by that so
nonsense applied even if it applied to
the simple surprise construct of a
one-dimensional cellular automata for
example yeah yeah but i mean actually
maybe i'm doing myself a bit too down it
was it was it was just as a theory was
coming through and i didn't really know
how to explain it but but we are going
to use assembly theory and cas but
instead automata but i'm i wanted to
what i was really curious about is why
people are marvel i mean you marvel cas
and their complexity and i said well
hang on that complexity is baked in
because if you play the game of life in
a ca you have to run it on a computer
you have to have a you have to do a
number of operations put in the boundary
conditions so is it surprising that you
get this structure out is it
manufactured by the boundary conditions
and and it is interesting because i
think
um
cellular automata running them
uh is teaching me something about what
real numbers are and aren't
and i haven't quite got there yet i was
playing on the aeroplane coming over i'm
just realized i have no idea what real
numbers are really
and they'll say well i do actually have
some notion what real numbers are um
and i think
thinking about real numbers as functions
rather than numbers is more appropriate
and then if you then apply that to cas
then you're saying well actually
um why am i seeing this complexity in
this in this rule
is it is it you know is it is it deter
you've got this deterministic system and
yet you get this incredible structure
coming out well isn't that what you'd
get with any real number as you
as you apply it as a function
and you're trying to read it out to an
arbitrary position
and i wonder if cas are just helping me
well my my misunderstanding of ca's
might be helping me understand them in
terms of real numbers i don't know what
you think yeah well the funk is
but
uh the devil's in the function
it's like which is the function that's
generating your real
number
like
that it seems like it's very important
the specific algorithm of that function
because some lead to something super
trivial some lead to something that's
all chaotic and some lead to things that
are
just walk that
fine line of complexity and we'll take a
structure i think we agree so let's take
it back a second so take the logistic
map or something logistic equation where
you have this equation
which is
um
you don't you don't know what's gonna
happen at n plus one but once you've
done n plus one you know full time you
can't predict it
for me cas and logistic equation feel
similar
and
and i think what's incredibly
interesting and i share
your
kind of
wonder at running a ca
but also i'm saying well what is it
about the boundary conditions and the
way i'm running that calculation so in
my group with my team we actually made a
chemical ca we made game of life we
actually made a physical grid i haven't
been out of publish this paper has been
trapped in purgatory for a long time but
we wrote up a paper how to do a chemical
formulation of the game of life which we
made a chemical computer and one little
cells and i was playing game of life
with the bz reactions each cell would
pulse on and off on and off on and off
we have little stirrer bars and we have
little gates yeah and we actually played
conway's game of life in there and we've
got structures in that we've got
structures in that game from the
chemistry that you wouldn't expect from
the actual ca so that's kind of cool in
the um because they're they're they're
interacting outside of the cell smile or
so what's happening is you're getting
noise so the thing is
that you've got this bz reaction it
gives on off on off on off but there's
also a wake
and those wakes constructively interfere
or in such a non-trivial way
that that's the non-deterministic
and the non-determinism in in in the
system gives very rich dynamics and i
was wondering if i could physically make
a chemical computer
with this ca um that gives me something
different that i can't get in a silicon
representation
of a ca where all the states are clean
because you don't have the noise
trailing into the next round you just
have the state so the the paper in
particular so
it's just a beautiful idea to use a
chemical computer to construct the
cellular automata and the famous one of
game of life but it's also interesting
as a really interesting scientific
question of whether some kind of random
perturbations or some source of
randomness
can uh
have a uh
significant
constructive effect on the complexity of
the system and indeed i mean whether
it's random or just non-deterministic
and can we bake in that non-determinism
at the beginning you know i wonder what
what is the i'm trying to think about
what is the encoding space the encoding
space is pretty big we have
um 49 stir ups of 49 cells
49 chem bits
all connected to one another in like an
analog computer but being read out
discreetly as they come the bz reaction
so just to say the bz reaction is a
chemical oscillator
and what happens in each cell is it goes
between red and blue so two russians
discovered it blues of zapakinsky i
think luzov first proposed it and
everyone said you're crazy it breaks the
second law and zabasinski said no it
doesn't break the second law it's
consuming a fuel
and so and then and and it's a like
there's a lot of uh um uh chemistry
hidden in the russian literature
actually
this because
russians just wrote it in russian they
didn't publish in english speaking
journalism it's heartbreaking actually
yeah it's
yeah sad and
it's great it's there right it's not
lost i'm sure we will find a way of
translating it properly well the
silver lining slash greater sadness of
all of this is there's probably ideas in
in english speaking like there's ideas
in certain disciplines
that
if discovered by other disciplines
would crack open some of the biggest
mysteries in those disciplines like
computer science for example
it's
uh
trying to solve
problems like nobody else has ever tried
to solve problems
as as if it's not already been all
addressed in cognitive science and
psychology mathematics in physics and
just whatever you want to economics even
but if if you look into that literature
you might be able to just discover some
beautiful ideas obviously russian is um
is an interesting case of that's because
there's a lot of translation but he said
there's a source of
fuel source of energy yeah yeah so with
the bz reaction you have a you have a an
acid in there called melonic acid yeah
and what happens is it it when it react
when it it power it's basically like a
battery that powers it and it loses co2
so decarboxylates it's just a chemical
reaction what that means we have to do
is continuously feed or we just keep the
bz reaction going in a in a long enough
time so it's it's like it's reversible
in time
but only like yeah only like but um but
it's fascinating i mean the team that
did it i'm really proud of their
persistence we made a we made a chemical
computer um
it can solve little problems it can
solve travelling salesman problems
actually nice um but like i said it's
called it's not any faster than a
regular computer is that something is
there something you can do maybe i'm not
sure i'm i'm not i think we can come up
with a way of solving problems also
really complex hard ones
um
because it's an analog computer and we
can we can
the it can energy minimize really
quickly it doesn't have to basically go
through every element in the matrix
like
flip it it just reads out so we can
actually do monte carlo by just shaking
the box
it's literally a box shaker
you don't actually have to encode the
shaking of the box in a silicon memory
and then just shuffle everything around
yeah and you could tell so analog it's
natural so
it's a uh it's an organic computer yeah
yeah so we're so i was playing around
with this and i was kind of annoying
some of my colleagues i'm wondering if
we could get to chemical supremacy like
quantum supremacy and i kind of
calculated how big
the the grid has to be so we can
actually start to solve problems faster
than the silicon computer but i'm not
willing to
um to state how that is yet because i'm
probably wrong it's not that i'm it's
any top secret thing is i want i think i
can make a chemical computer that can
solve optimization problems faster than
the silicon computer
that's fascinating and but then you're
unsure how big that has to be yeah i
think i mean it might be a big box hard
to shake it might be exactly a big box
hard to shake and basically a bit sloppy
did we answer the the question about uh
do uh cellular timer exist outside the
mind
we didn't but i would i would posit that
they don't and i i and
but i think minds can well so the mind
is fundamental
what's the what i mean well i mean sorry
so let's go back so as a physical
phenomena do cas exist in physical
reality right
i would say they probably don't exist
outside the human mind but now i've
constructed them they exist in computer
memories they exist in my lab they exist
on paper so they are they emerge from
the human mind
i'm just interested in because stephen
wolfram likes cas a lot of people like
cas and likes to think of them as
minimal computational elements
i'm just saying well do they exist in
reality or are they a representation of
a simple machine that's just very
elegant to implement
so there's a platonic question i guess
yeah i mean it's um
there's initial conditions
there's a memory in the system
there are simple rules that dictate the
evolution of the system
so what exists the idea the rules the
yeah people are using cas as models for
things in reality to say hey
look you can you can do this thing in a
ca
and my my when i see this i'm saying oh
that's cool but what does that tell me
about reality where's the ca in in space
right it's a mathematical object so for
people who don't know cellular automata
there's a is usually a grid whether it's
one-dimensional two-dimensional
three-dimensional and it evolves by
simple local rules like you die or born
if the neighbors
are alive or dead and
it turns out if you have
with certain kinds of initial conditions
and with certain kinds of very simple
rules you can uh create like arbitrarily
complex and beautiful systems and to me
um
you know whether uh
drugs are involved or not i can sit back
for hours and enjoy the
the mystery of it how such complexity
emerges
it gives me almost like you know people
talk about religious experiences
it gives me a
sense that you get to
have a glimpse
at the uh origin of this whole thing
whatever is creating
this
complexity from such
simplicity is the very thing that
brought my mind to life
this me the human
uh our our human civilization
and
yes
those constructs are pretty trivial
they're
i mean that's part of their magic is
even in this trivial
framework you could see the emergence or
especially in this trivial framework you
could see the emergence of complexity
from simplicity i guess what lee you're
saying is that
this is not you know
um
this is
highly unlike
systems we've seen the physical world
even though they probably carry some of
the same
magic like mechanistically
i mean i'm saying that the the
the operating system that ca has to
exist on is quite complex right
and so i wonder if you're getting the
complexity out of the ca from the
boundary conditions the operating system
the underlying digital computer oh wow
so you those are some strong words
against the ea's then no not against i
mean i'm in the i'm in love with cas as
well right i'm just saying
they aren't as trivial as people think
they are incredible
to get to that richness you have to
iterate billions of times
and you need a display
and you need a math coprocessor and you
need a von neumann machine based on a
turing machine with digital error
correction and states wow to think that
for the simplicity of a grid
you're basically saying a grid is not
simple yeah
it requires incredible complexity to
bring a grid to life yeah
yeah that's what then what is simple
that's all i wanted to say i agree with
you with a wonder of cas i just think
but remember this we take so much for
granted well the ca is resting on
because von neumann and and firemen
weren't showing weren't seeing these
elaborate structures they could not get
that far
yeah but that's the limitation of their
mind yeah exactly
but i i think that's
the question is
whether the essential elements of the
cellular automata
is um
is present
without all the complexities required to
build a computer
my intuition
the reason i find it incredible is that
yeah my intuition is yes it might look
different
uh there might not be a grill structure
a grid like structure
but
local interactions operating under
simple rules
and resulting in
multi-hierarchical complex structures
feels like a thing that's doesn't
require a computer i agree but coming
back to von neumann and feynman and
wolfram
though their minds the non-trivial minds
to create those architectures and do it
and
to put on those
state transitions
and i think that something that's really
incredibly interesting
that um is understanding how the human
mind builds those straight those state
transition machines
you i could see how deeply in love with
the idea of memory you are so it's it's
like
how much of e equals mc squared
like
is more than an equation it has albert
einstein in it
like you're saying like you can't just
say this is a
uh like
the equations of physics are a really
good
simple capture
of a physical phenomena it is also has
the mem that equation has the memory of
the humans
absolutely
absolutely yeah
but i don't i don't know if you're
implying this i don't uh that's a
beautiful
idea but i don't know if
i'm comfortable with that
sort of diminishing the power of that
equation no no it enhances what's on the
shoulders it enhances i think it
enhances it it's not that equation is a
minimal compressed representation of
reality right yeah we can use machine
learning or or max tech marks um ai
firemen to find lots of solutions for
gravity but isn't it wonderful that the
laws that we do find are the maximally
compressed representations
yeah but that representation you can now
give it as
i guess the universe has the memory of
einstein with that representation
but then you can now give it as a gift
for free yeah yeah it's very memorable
civilizations i just had to go for a lot
of pain together but it's low memory so
physic i say that physics and chemistry
and biology are the same discipline
they're just physics
laws in physics there's no such thing as
a law in physics it's just low memory
stuff
because you've got low memory stuff you
can things reoccur quickly
as you get building more memory you get
to chemistry so things become more
contingent when you get to biology more
contingent still and then technology so
the more memory you need the more your
laws are local
that's all i'm saying and that the the
less memory the more the laws are
universal because they're not laws they
are just low memory states
you